Michael Saylor the CEO of microstrategy
and the holder of over 125 000 Bitcoin
was recently on CNBC he continues to be
a fantastic spokesman for Bitcoin in the
mainstream media during the conversation
he was asked about market dynamics and
he had a really great framework in which
he said there's three main players in
the Bitcoin market today he stated that
there are Bitcoin Maximus there are
technocrats and there are Traders those
three people are all constantly battling
for who controls the market and what
will happen to the supply the demand and
ultimately the price of Bitcoin here's
the exact segment where he stated these
three people and what his thoughts were
around how they're controlling the
market today there's three types of
investors in Bitcoin there's the Traders
there's the technocrats and there's the
uh there's the maximalist the
maximalists are are buying the stuff to
give to their grandchildren and they
just dollar cost average and they're all
in already so they don't control the
market the technocrats think it's the
next big Tech Network like Google or
Facebook when they're feeling bullish on
technology they're buying when they're
feeling bearish on technology they're
selling the Traders think it's either a
correlated asset or an uncorrelated
asset the risk assets depending on their
mood right now they think it's
correlated to risk and so if they're
selling risk they're selling Bitcoin
it's obviously not a tech stock it is
actually the ultimate risk-off asset in
time over the course of four five six
seven years everybody figures it out but
right now the Traders and the
technocrats control the market trading
of Bitcoin and it's it's a function of
the tug of war between them and the mood
and the market this is a fantastic point
because ultimately what happened pre
maybe 2020 was that really it was just
bitcoiners in the market people would
learn about Bitcoin they would get
excited about the potential future that
it laid out and then they would start to
acquire Bitcoin but these were all
pretty much retail investors there were
no major financial institutions there
were no public companies there were no
Sovereign wealth funds or any type of
large institutional asset allocators
those individuals for about 13 years
they continue to just dollar costs
average into Bitcoin they were using it
as a reserve asset and therefore we had
these really nice clean boom and bust
Cycles the price of Bitcoin acted like
the marketing department as the price
went up more people heard about Bitcoin
and they would come in and they would
try to buy some of it of course it would
get overheated there would be a crash
and then some of the people would get
flushed out but this cycle repeated over
and over again when it was just retailed
but then of course once the pandemic hit
and the central bank and politicians
started step in and intervene in the
market and they were able to inject
trillions of dollars into the economy
and they were able to manipulate
interest rates down to a zero percent
interest rate environment now all of a
sudden Traders and these technocrats
they needed to go find a new asset Paul
Tudor Jones Stanley drucken Miller and
many other Legends of Wall Street at the
end of 2020 started talking about
Bitcoin as an inflation hedge asset they
stated that it would be the fastest
[ __ ] course in that inflation hedge
asset bucket that's exactly what
happened as those Traders came in and as
those technocrats came in they simply
viewed Bitcoin as a risk asset now as
Michael so eloquently pointed out they
got more cash than the retail investors
those retail investors don't care though
they continue to just dollar cost
average into Bitcoin whether the price
is up or down but the Traders and
technocrats they care more than just
about Bitcoin they obviously look at the
underlying fundamentals and the market
dynamics but they're also looking at
things like the interest rate and so as
we headed into the end of 2021 as the
central bankers and many pundits on
mainstream media started talking about
the Federal Reserve increasing interest
rates a lot of those Traders a lot of
those technocrats they said oh my God
risk assets are not going to do well in
a higher interest rate environment they
started to sell all those risk assets
they went risk off and because they
treat Bitcoin like a risk asset they all
started to sell Bitcoin as well now
that's great if you're just a bitcoiner
and you simply are a reach tell person
who continues the dollar cost average
means you're picking up cheaper Bitcoin
today than you were three or four months
ago but of course that means the prices
come down because those Traders and
those technocrats they continue to dump
Bitcoin because they simply go with the
whims of the short-term Market sentiment
and so naturally what's gonna happen
here is as the FED continues to raise
interest rates my guess is that Bitcoin
will trade sideways or down it'll
continue to suffer because a lot of
those Traders and those technocrats
they're selling and they don't plan to
stop but over time eventually the
Traders and technocrats they run out of
Bitcoin to sell sure they got a lot of
money but naturally they can't sell
forever and so they're just simply
transitioning that Bitcoin from
short-term weekends to long-term strong
hands and once the bitcoiners get
control of Bitcoin once they still have
that Bitcoin and they don't move it for
a year or more which right now about 65
percent of Bitcoin is then all of a
sudden you get in an environment where
you get an illiquid market supply and
you simply need some sort of short-term
Catalyst to make the price explode
upwards we saw this happen at the end of
2020 and my guess is that we're going to
see it happen again in the next 24
months or so but right now we're in this
transition period where the Traders and
technocrats they're dumping Bitcoin they
don't want any risk assets they want to
go buy things like Berkshire Hathaway
and value stocks but while they're doing
that the bitcoiners are just picking up
cheap Bitcoin they're making the market
more and more illiquid we continue to
see Bitcoin pulled off of exchanges we
continue to see bitcoiners holding with
strong hands they're not selling they're
handing the Bitcoin to their grandkids
and ultimately the bitcoiners will get
control of this Market again the Bulls
will be in control and the Traders and
technocrats they'll learn a long-term
lesson that bitcoin's not a trading
asset Bitcoin is a store of value it
literally is built to survive high
inflation environments holding Bitcoin
over the next 10 to 20 years is likely
to be one of the easiest things people
can do
the Traders and the technocrats might
learn this lesson the hard way hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time